the MIT ballroom dance team is an
organization of about 100 members we
have grad students undergrad students as
well as MIT affiliates and their
partners we don't have to be a dancer or
have an experience in order to join the
team we don't have tryouts and we have a
motley of different types of classes to
help you get started
per team itself originated from a
ballroom dance club that was established
in the 1970s and because of the
popularity of ballroom dancing
competitions several Club members
decided to start a ballroom dance team
because they wanted to compete and focus
more on the technical aspects of dancing
rather than the social aspect so we have
a bunch of classes we teach all the way
from beginner all the way to champ and
we have instruction in the four
different styles that comprise ballroom
and it chosen in the way we compete in
the way we perform and we are probably
one of the stronger teams collegiate
teams in the country today
we also host one of the largest
competitions nationally where we have
almost a thousand competitors come in
which is very exciting
focuses on social dancing which means
that we do cover all of the regular ball
advances and we do teach basically all
of them but it's at a pretty relaxed
kind of pace we don't actually require
them to have any partners or any
previous experience it's supposed to be
an environment that's just friendly and
casual a place where people can feel
comfortable coming and going although
the team and the club have slightly
different ways in which we operate in
the end it all comes not the same thing
we all love ballroom dancing and often
you find team members involved in
running some of the things that the club
doesn't and some of the club members our
team members now some people you know
might want to choose to dance one style
competitively but they still want to
learn the other style just to be able to
dance it socially so we are we are part
of one big system there is a pretty
large variety of people's and we do
welcome everybody it ranges from you
know the MIT students and then there are
also some faculty and staff and then
other people who they're just in the
community and they like learning how to
dance
one aspect that really plays into it is
just how passionate people here are at
MIT
you'll see somebody light up about you
know phytoplankton and then at the very
next moment they'll be talking about how
they just love this one Samba song and I
think it's this passion that really
drives people to be willing to commit as
much time as necessary to perfect not
only their academic work but also you
know their dance technique or any other
extracurricular activities that they do
you